this right here is a screenshot of
probably the page that you're looking at
this is the Khan Academy youtube channel
and I thought I would walk you through
not only the YouTube channel but our
website and our web application so that
you see what's available and hopefully
you'll find something that's useful a
good place to start is the playlists and
YouTube lets me list ten of the top
playlist but there's actually a lot more
than that in order to see all the
playlist you just scroll down here and
once again this is that you know
youtube.com slash Khan Academy and see
all the playlists you click here see all
playlists and then you'll see the list
of all of them so not just the top 10
and you know if you look right here some
of those playlists that aren't included
on that you know I have one on the
Paulson plan I have one on statistics I
have all these California Standards
tests I don't know if gmat problem
solving was on the top one but if you
want the complete list of play let's
click on that little link i just showed
you and the playlist really are the best
way to get the updated list of the
videos i'm making because it usually
takes me a little lag between uploading
it on to youtube and then putting it on
our website although our website i think
has a much better navigation structure
for accessing the site so once you if
you're interested in a given playlist
for example we see maybe you are
interested in physics just click on that
playlist and you'll see them all in the
best I could do to figure out the order
that you should watch them in for the
most part they were recorded in and with
an order in mind but sometimes we switch
gears from projectile motion to
electricity and magnetism so it's just a
suggestion that the order you should
look at them in and I'll do more on that
on the Khan Academy the actual the
actual website so to get to the website
you could just click on khanacademy org
I don't know if you could read this up
here but is it the goal of really the
site is to just give you a better
navigation structure for what's already
on YouTube and you see here I have to
update this we actually have over 800
videos this says 700 but if you see them
all here they're all listed by subject
matter some videos a few of them are
listed in more than one subject if it
makes sense the event vectors are in
physics
and in precalculus and there's a bunch
of concepts like that especially in the
financial playlist because it's either
700 videos and the ones that we're
really important to kind of structure a
little bit better than just a list I've
made it I've produced them on separate
pages so for example the s80 preparation
you click right here on you know more
and I'll actually go to a page that has
all of the s80 all of the s80 problems /
/ what page they're on or what section
they are on and actually by the problems
so if you go here and I've told you I've
you know I recommend this in this on
this page right here just go by the SAE
book we've worked through all I think
it's 405 problems in it and we explained
how to do them so if you don't know how
to do problem number 13 on page 584 you
just click right there and it'll explain
how to do problem 13 on page 584 so this
is the screenshot that it should just
come up and this is just plugs in to
youtube so if you don't know how to do
that problem just click there and you'll
hear someone who sounds suspiciously
like myself explaining how to do problem
well starting problem number 11 anyway I
don't want to confuse you too much so
let me close this so just going back to
the actual site all eight hundred or so
videos are there and then if you want to
use the adaptive web application we've
made and actually this was the the
genesis of Khan Academy to start with
the web application we later integrated
the videos into that although now the
videos have taken on a life of their own
you click here for the free adaptive
math program and have it right here
you'll get a screen like that you can
log in you can register first of all
it's all free and as user name it means
login is my cousin
I don't want to remember the password
and then so this is my cousin's account
and so it'll start all students at
literally one plus one equals two and it
probably makes sense to show you what
the knowledge map looks like you click
on the knowledge map and then you should
see a screen that looks something like
this it's important to use firefox
because we use we take advantage of
cutting-edge technology but right here
you started basic edition and as you get
streaks of those right it moves you up
to each of the next concepts so these
lines right here are just they just show
the dependency for the next concept so
once you know basic multiplication
you're ready for level two
multiplication and basic division and
this goes all the way up to it goes up
to you know this is these are a lot of
algebra or algebra two concepts and it
even goes to precalculus and a little
bit of calculus and some trigonometry
and geometry here the modules covered in
the web application or subset of the
videos the videos go much more advanced
into differential equations and
multivariable calculus and of course
finance and economics and our goal with
both of these is actually to cover
everything everything you might ever
want to learn so one day there this
knowledge Matt might go off into the you
know law or grammar and you know I make
videos on philosophy and history and all
of the rest but I'm doing the
low-hanging fruit where I think there's
a lot of demand first but I'm very open
to recommend suggestions and
recommendations and I'm trying the best
I can to keep pace fine all right now I
have two or three unfinished playlist
and I will get to those eventually but
this is the knowledge map and that
should that's kind of a a curriculum for
the students and it's see they get to
see where they are on it so my cousin
right here he's become proficient in
these brown modules and these light
brown modules and these orange modules
are the leading edge of what he's
working on right now let me show you
what that means in the context of his
exercises so if he clicks on exercises i
think is taking a little extra time
because i'm capturing my screen these
are the leading edge modules that he's
working on right now so for example if
you
you know with lissy multiplying level
one multiplying expressions this would
be something that he should be working
on right now if you go there gives you
these algebraic binomials and they wants
you to multiply them and if you know the
answer you can just click on the answer
and and your streak would build but if
you don't know how to do it it'll
actually give you hints so you every
time you click hint it'll tell you a
step of essentially how to use the
distributive property to solve this and
what well what I think is cool about
this is that it'll generate an infinite
number of problems for you so analed and
with these problem it gets its own
custom solution so you'll never run out
of problems to do so if you takes you a
thousand problems to figure out how to
multiply these algebraic expressions it
will give you a hundred problems and if
you know how to do it you know if well
let's say you did wrong and you check
your answer it'll give you a frowny face
and it but if once you know the answer
you click there and you check it and
will give you a smiley face it should
give you a smiley face oh no I didn't
check on the right one it's that one
need your smiley face and you correct go
to the next question it generates a new
problem if you are very comfortable with
this type of problem and you want the
system to know about that and we use
this really for analytics purposes and
if you have a teacher or guardian who
wants to know how you're doing you can
actually rate your own comfort level
this right here this streak this is
actually as you get problems right it
will grow in length and to become
proficient in a given module you have to
get five or ten in a row right and if
this problem isn't enough and the hints
aren't enough you're like gee I have no
idea to even how to approach these you
just click on video and a video box will
open up and videos that explain how to
multiply expressions in this case will
start up and then and then you're you're
hopefully good to go you watch this
video and you say well now I know how to
do that and now I can just do five or
ten problems in a row and I become
proficient in that concept I think I say
welcome to the presentation too much but
I think you get the general idea so
going back to exercise is not all the
exercises look just like that some are
more visual than others let me so for
example let me find
that will be more visual for you so
level one functions would look something
like this actually would look exactly
like this so it's asking what's the you
know this is a function definition it's
actually a visual function definition it
says what's F of 4 well if you know the
input is four and then f of 4 is 3 but
if you don't know how to do that you
click on hint and it says okay you go to
x is equal 4 and it draws that in for
you and since then f of 4 is equal to 3
so it really kind of teaches you to read
this this visual function definition and
this is my cousin's work he's gotten
five in a row and that's why he became
proficient in it he's very comfortable
with it so there's a whole range of
modules that you can work on and we're
always building new ones and if you're
interested in contributing let me know
and we actually keep track of very
granular data so if you just want a a
sense of things let me see this is the
one that and I'll do a separate video
for teachers and educators so they
really see the level of granularity that
we keep track of it khan academy really
literally keep track of when problems
are done you know when students are
watching videos how long is taking them
to do videos anything you would want to
know about and aggregating the data in
terms of you know what's the standard
deviation where students might need more
help in certain concepts in all of the
rest but it gets walls keeping kind of
fine granular a data on everything my
cousin is doing and actually well I
won't go into that right now i'll do
that on the analytics videos but this
should give you a pretty good sense of
at least the resources that are
available to you i think for most of you
the video library really is you know at
the Khan Academy channel really is kind
of the the most useful or maybe the
easiest to use but I do encourage you to
use the web app and and please contact
me if you have any questions